this week ESPN obtained emails and text
messages that provided more information
on a rape allegation against Mavericks
our former Nick kristaps porzingis the
acquisition that ESPN had was
essentially a handwritten agreement
between porzingis and his accuser in
which he allegedly promised to pay sixty
eight thousand dollars to her brother's
college fund in order to keep quiet he
never paid that money according to her
and now she is suing now listen this is
gotta be the best sister EVER if she's
just like you know what i was sexually
assaulted got to think about my brother
on this one you know got to who got to
pay down those student loans make it
worth it the story in the document came
out that that was signed
according to her lawyers that night so
he played in a game that day that night
he tore his ACL in that game so it was a
big moment for his career she lives in
his apartment building and according to
her they stayed together until the
morning and by the end of it he signed
that agreement we also he got drunk with
his brothers his brothers were there
that's like it's like there was a video
documenting that they got did shots of
tequila they go back to his place
they're getting drunk I think she may
have drunk a drink with him I might be
wrong about that but then she says she
went up later on late that night to get
an autograph
was that was that her excuse and then he
assaulted her she says they spent the
night together he agreed to sixty five
grand and then and then pulled out of
the agreement like he pulls out of so
many things and then and then she went
to the police I you know I think the I
feel bad for the brother you know who
thought this was his big his big chance
anyway this is a crazy story just keeps
getting crazier I think it's crazy that
Mark Cuban when they made the trade from
the Knicks to the to the Mavs they
everyone knew about it the NBA is known
about this for quite some time I don't
know what to think it's a there's a lot
of different stories here but I'll tell
you this we here at the rosenthal and
Jeselnik vanity project
junior vice president I it up you
did let's go back we here because I want
to make I want to make sure this point
is driven a home like we would drive
home a lover afterwards even though
we're demanding we would demand to drive
them home to make sure they're safe no
matter how drunk we were that's right as
a threesome we one of us would be fine
we here at the Jeselnik and Rosenthal
vanity project we believe the victims
Greg what's our next headline I mean I
could just say it you don't have to ask
me what the next headline is every time
but I want to know because I feel like
you know that last one was a hardcore
one you know Erica's corner was overtly
sexual in a way that I think made us all
uncomfortable you know I like I feel
like whatever Stu's doing on his
honeymoon right now ain't is sexy I said
we're doing I mean this is this is a
pretty sexy story too like if you like
the last 15 minutes of the show you are
gonna love the news out of Australia
this week that an Aussie appeals court
decided on Friday they dismissed a
bullying case against a former boss by
an ex-employee of his who alleged that
the boss repeatedly farted around him
and that constant constituted bullying
over the course of nine months he's
suing him for 1.3 million dollars for
farting upwards of 5 to 6 times a day in
the man's small windowless office and he
claims he didn't strictly to bully him
but he would walk into the office and
let him go and then leave yeah the
supervisors name was Greg short which
just feels like a perfect name for a guy
who would go into another guy's office
up I've been the thing that really got
me was it was five to six times a day
but they didn't work in the same office
the guy would come in it was his boss
yeah not in the same office but he would
come in and there's no windows it's a
small office and then he would fart on
the guy you know many times a day and he
would talk about it wasn't just like he
would kind of like sneak up and and do
it he
you know make make jokes about it and
he's like he thought it would be funny
if he did it once or twice but he was
saying this guy did it like five or six
times a day every day
that was so three was the breaking point
like like once you get past one or two
that's too much I liked it in Australia
bullying is illegal but they can't
define bullying
I had a science teacher my freshman year
who was a crazy person who was like
pretty normal in all aspects but if you
ever smelled anything that smelled like
it could be a fart he would like close
the door the class and yell at all of us
be like guys who did it who farted right
now and one time he is cleaning out an
aquarium with a with like a vacuum and
the smell is horrific because it's like
it's fish whatever is in an
aquarium it smells so bad
and he stops the the vacuum pulls all
the guys into the other room and goes
guys who themselves and we're all
laughing so he's getting a matter
inaudible act and we have no idea what
he's talking about he brings us all back
into class and in front of the girls and
the guys gives us a speech about how if
anyone ever passes gas in his classroom
ever again
they're getting kicked out and they're
going to the office and we're trying to
hold it together so badly and I have the
presence of mind to raise my hand while
he's yelling and the guy who sat next to
me was a friend of mine named Justin
Baer shout out to Justin and I raised my
hand and I say mr. Leeds while you were
talking
Justin farted three times stack goes
Justin get up and get out of here and
Justin like on the verge of tears is
like you're not gonna tell him you're
joking and I'm laughing too hard to say
anything and he got sent to the office
that day which was one of the funniest
things what do you tell the principal
I like fart like he said he like he pass
gas and then I had another friend who
got in the same trouble where mr. Leeds
yelled at him for farting he's like mr.
Leeds it's a bodily function I can't
help it and mr. Leeds Centre in the
office and the principal says so mr.
Leeds tells me that you told him that
you'll fart whenever you want nothing
you can do to stop you he was like no
why is this guy so crazy
he's a biology teacher who couldn't
stand I'm a biological what happened to
mr. Leeds as a child that led to this
maybe he was bullied I think looking
back
I think it's very possible that mr.
Leeds smoked marijuana to her throughout
the school I think that was his his
problem he was uh he was a fun teacher
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say he
inspired anyone to do anything except
except never fart the the bus the
weirdest like he didn't really teach you
much but he taught you that mm-hmm
that's something that the what's
strangest part of this story was though
that this all happened over the course
of 11 months a decade ago why is he only
suing the guy now he's been holding this
in mentally for that entire time and
even though this got dismissed he's
trying to take it to the essentially the
Supreme Court in Australia he was
sometimes you know speaking of
biologists and that's when people fart
it doesn't smell right away you know I
mean as a little delay on it so it could
have been 11 years you don't know how
things work down in Australia Thailand
flushed backwards it's a it's a
different kind of place what is bullying
that would you consider our actions like
last week these you were very sensitive
about the way that Eric and I don't
always lift you up as you know the star
of the show we bring up embarrassing
stories you know you like what are you
saying we Erica's never once brought up
on you - yeah you threw her into that -
last week you were saying that you know
we don't do good find myself what good
does that constitute bullying no I
haven't been bullied in quite some time
okay another mr. lead story mr. Leeds
and his is he was like you get extra
credit if you get a pet and bring it in
here and keep it in the tank like you
can get a fish people had piranhas
people with different things and me and
uh my friend Jason Busan shout-out to
Jason went to a store and bought a snake
and brought like a tiny little baby
snake it looked so cool we called it
brimstone love and we put it in a cage
we're like mr. Leeds how do we take care
of this thing and he goes I'll just put
sand in there like a little bit of water
and put a heat lamp over it the next day
the snake is dead
it's kidneys have exploded from
dehydration and overheating and I go mr.
Leeds what the hell like what the hell
is this in heat mr. Leeds goes oh I
don't like snakes and we're like all
right did we still get extra credit cool
you
[Music]